>> Sean: BREAKING TONIGHT,
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES OF
CALIFORNIA HAS NOTIFIED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HE'S SUBMITTING
EIGHT CRIMINAL REFERRALS
ALLEGING SERIOUS MISCONDUCT IN
THE TRUMP RUSSIA PROBE.
HE JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US ABOUT THIS?
YOU SAY IN YOUR LETTER, WHICH I
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME, THAT IT'S
SERIOUS.
WHEN WILL WE KNOW WHO AND WHAT
FOR?
>> WELL, WE DON'T KNOW IF YOU'LL
EVER KNOW WHO.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IF YOU
FOLLOW THE RUSSIA HOAX CLOSELY,
IF I GAVE YOU SEVEN GUESSES,
YOU'D PROBABLY GET THE FIVE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE REFERRED.
SO THERE'S FIVE DIRECT REFERRALS
BASED ON LYING, OBSTRUCTION,
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION AND
LEAKING.
WE HAVE A GLOBAL LEAKS REFERRAL,
WHICH INVOLVES A FEW REPORTERS
BUT COULD INVOLVE MULTIPLE
PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT MANY
PEOPLE BECAUSE I THINK THEY
PROBABLY ONLY HAVE A FEW SOURCES
WITHIN THESE AGENCIES.
THEN YOU HAVE CONSPIRACY
REFERRALS.
ONE IS BASED ON INTELLIGENCE.
THE SECOND ONE IS BASED ON FISA
ACCUSE AND OTHER MATTERS.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE STAND.
THOSE ARE THE EIGHT REFERRALS AT
THIS POINT.
WE'RE PREPARED TO BRIEF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO -- WE
HAVE A FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY IN
CONGRESS NOW, JOHN RATCLIFFE
THAT SERVES ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE AND THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SO HE WILL GO WITH ME TO BRIEF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
>> Sean: WE DO KNOW FROM THE
NUNES AND THE GRASSLEY MEMOS ON
FISA, THE BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION, PAGES 10-12, 17 TO
34 AND THE LAST ONE IS IMPORTANT
I'M TOLD.
THE BULK OF THAT INFORMATION
CAME FROM HILLARY CLINTON'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
THAT IS A FRAUD BEFORE THE
COURT, IS IT NOT, SIR?
CONSPIRACY EVEN.
>> SEAN, LET'S JUST -- LET ME
MAKE IT AS CLEAR AS I POSSIBLY
CAN.
OKAY?
NOW THANK GOD WE HAVE AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT CALLS
SPYING FOR WHAT IT IS.
IN LATE 2015, EARLY 2016, SPYING
WE AGAIN ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT INFORMATION LEAKED THAT LED
TO WHAT THEY CONSIDERED TO BE
LEGAL SPYING THAT BEGAN, THAT
THEY HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THEY
STARTED DOING AT THE END OF
JULY.
YOU JUST HAD CARTER PAGE ON.
THEY CONSIDER THAT ALL LEGAL
SPYING.
THEY THEN LEAKED THAT
INFORMATION SHORTLY AFTER THE
ELECTION ALL THROUGH THE SPRING.
THAT WAS LEAKING OUT.
WHY?
TO CREATE A NARRATIVE THAT
DONALD TRUMP SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
PRESIDENT, THAT HE'S A RUSSIAN
ASSET, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
SO SPYING AND LEAKING.
THEN YOU HAVE THE CULMINATION OF
THE ULTIMATE SPYING WHERE YOU
HAVE THE FBI DIRECTOR SPYING ON
THE PRESIDENT, TAKING NOTES,
ILLEGALLY LEAKING THE NOTES OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
WHY?
SO THEY CAN APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO SPY ON AN ACTING
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THERE'S A LOT OF SPYING AND A
LOT OF LEAKING AND THAT'S AS
CLEAR AS I CAN PUT IT.
>> Sean: I WON'T PUSH ANY
FURTHER.
I UNDERSTAND.
I WOULD ASK YOU OFTEN -- YOU
HAVE MORE INFORMATION THAN I.
I WOULD SAY, IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT I'VE SAID TONIGHT THAT IS
WRONG?
YOU SAY NO.
THEN I'D ASK YOU THE NEXT
QUESTION.
AM I OVER THE TARGET?
I WANT TO BE RIGHT.
I HAVE A LOT OF SOURCES AND I'M
PUTTING PIECES OF THE PUZZLE
TOGETHER.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE CANNOT GIVE ME
INFORMATION.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THANKS TO CONGRESSMAN DOUG
COLLINS, WE HAVE THE CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY OF A LOT OF PEOPLE.
NELLY, BRUCE OHR, LISA PAGE,
JAMES BAKER, THE GENERAL COUNSEL
WHO SAID THE FOLLOWING.
DESCRIBE CLINTON'S BEHAVIOR AS
RELATES TO THE SERVER WHERE SHE
HAD TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON IT AS ALARMING
AND APPALLING AND ARGUED THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT SHE SHOULD BE
CHARGED.
AND PAGE AND STRZOK SAID, BOTH
OF THEM, THEY HAD NO CONTROL
OVER THAT INVESTIGATION AT ALL.
ALTHOUGH STRZOK HIMSELF DID THE
INTERVIEW, ALLOWED TWO OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE INTERVIEW, WHICH
IS UNHEARD OF AND WAS WRITING
HER EXONERATION IN MAY BEFORE
INTERVIEWING HER IN JULY AND
EXONERATING HER THREE DAYS
LATER.
COMEY DID THAT PART.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
INVESTIGATION TO HILLARY WAS A
RIGGED INVESTIGATION AND SHOULD
BEGIN ANEW?
>> LOOK, I DON'T KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T LOOK AT ALL
THAT INFORMATION.
I WILL SAY THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW
DESTROYING A SERVER THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS NOT OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT POINT --
>> Sean: WITH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON IT.
>> WE'RE STILL WAITING ON
TRANSCRIPTS WITH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON IT.
I WANT TO REMIND THE VIEWERS, WE
STILL HAVE TRANSCRIPTS FROM OUR
INVESTIGATION SITTING AT THE DNI
THAT STILL HAVE NOT BEEN
DECLASSIFIED.
THOSE NEED TO COME OUT THAT WILL
GIVE MORE TRANSPARENCY TO
EVERYTHING GOING ON WITH THE
TRANSCRIPTS THAT YOU'RE SEEING
NOW.
>> Sean: THE LAST INTERVIEW I
HAD WITH THE PRESIDENT, HE SAID
HE WOULD RELEASE THE FISA
APPLICATIONS, THE GANG OF EIGHT,
THE 302 MATERIALS.
WHEN AMERICANS SEE THAT, WILL
THEY BE SHOCKED IN IF SO, ON A
SCALE OF 1-10, HOW SHOCKED?
>> WELL, LOOK, WHAT I'VE SAID
AND I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, IF YOU
THOUGHT USING DIRT FROM A
CAMPAIGN IS BAD, YOU'LL THINK
THIS IS EQUALLY AS BAD.
IF YOU DIDN'T THINK IT WASN'T
BAD, YOU WON'T CARE.